il ment
mode de jeu
et parfois parler
même si je ne triche jamais au poker
voilà dick rivers le mauvais joueur
extrait de son album
dans ce nouvel album il ya des chansons
de niro qu'elle celle là d'une chanson
de nick et 3d de benjamin biolay francis
cabrel
j'ai dit oui mathieu mathieu boogaerts
peter kingsbery et si vous appris aura
fait les cpe jeunes comment te donne
vite ça ressemble en rien à ce que j'ai
fait jusqu'à maintenant
non parce que je paie mon vrai métier
qui tamisent 5 mars et j'espère et ça a
toujours bien marché je ne touche pas le
fait pas de problème de ce côté-là
maison que j'ai 100 drucker en plus
bravo ça sert à rendre au caire et j'ai
pris beaucoup de plaisir à disons à
faire mon métier qui est un métier
d'interprète aujourd'hui à beaucoup
d'auteurs compositeurs interprètes et
moi mon métier c'est de chanter je pense
qu'à une véritable osmose c'est à dire
une complicité un véritable amour de la
musique et de respect mutuel entre ses
aplombs ça cette jeune génération et moi
alors hervé forneri c'est votre vrai nom
oui vous êtes né à nice en 1945 comme
vous chers amis et voilà votre père
avait une boucherie
exactement comme le père de denise fabre
c'est marrant comme les fils de boucher
niçois ont bien réussi bien avait un
autre os il y avait tout bon ouais dont
le père était non je crois qu'ils l'ont
été aussi dans la bouche
alors à la fin des années 50 vous
découvrez les mots magiques coca cola
rock'n'roll blue jeans grâce à la
présence de la flotte américaine dans la
rade de villefranche mais c'est vrai que
souvent le rock'n'roll est arrivée en
france par des gens qui habitaient près
des bases amérique mais comme bashung
c'était dans l'est de la france
gérard depardieu à châteauroux est
absolument donc vous c'est ça qu'ils ont
mis en contact avec l'amérique
oui moi aussi loin de même mémoire
remonte jeudi à l'âge de 7 ans dans
sortait de l'école y avait des dmp des
amériques des américains qui nous
donnaient des chewing gum les trucs
comme ça et puis plus tard il me donnait
des cigarettes
quand on était adolescent bon et puis
c'est vrai qu'avec mes parents quand
j'étais petit j'allais souvent visité
les porte-avions dans la raab il de main
franche et donc j'aime manger du
pop-corn j'aime manger des hot dogs
avant le reste des français quoi vous
essayez devenir chanteur quand vous
écoutez pour la première fois un titre
d'elvis presley fameux à brac hôtel est
un blues d'ailleurs guespin europe
vous dites si elvis n'avait pas existé
l'europe n'en serait pas là c'est lui
qui a fait passer cette musique de noirs
chez les blancs elvis c'est jésus oui si
on sûr c'est une image si on part en
part du principe non la crèche n'est pas
l'alcool
si on part du principe que le
rock'n'roll on peut considérer ça comme
une religion à ce moment là elvis
devient jésus le fils de dieu ce qui
fait passer cette musique de un côté un
petit peu obscur au sens propre et au
sens figuré
chez les blancs donc je veux dire lennon
que j'ai très bien connu dit exactement
la même chose j'en ai sélectionné
bien sûr je suis copain avec paul
mccartney j'ai connu jimmy hunt quand il
était guitariste des beatles
non c'est vrai mais bien sûr il habitait
deux ans et comme 16,2 ne doit pas bon
ben je crois pas et pourtant
mais allons-y qui vous connaissez les
échos neil lennon mccartney marcel amont
jimi hendrix janis joplin que j'ai connu
à londres j'étais très ami avec brian
jones des rolling stones je suis très
ami avec bill wyman toujours que je vais
voir en concert chaque fois qu'il vient
à paris
je sais pas moi parce que j'ai connue
elle vise bien sûr mais en 69 à las
vegas mais ça va écouter on est scotché
un l'avouer peut vous arrêter là on est
on est absolument scandaleux ces listes
on s'assure même connu non à non je suis
trop jeune non j'ai même que je connais
georges locas votre fille était avec lui
pendant trois ans oui donc jésus pour ça
que l'année dernière j'étais invité ces
pratiques les gosses france a même connu
georges w bush quand il était gouverneur
de texas hold up
voilà enfin voilà l'histoire c'est qu'on
vous découvrez grâce aux aux bateaux
ancrés dans la rade de villefranche
la mairie vous découvrez le vice
président est jésus oui et à l'âge de 14
ans vous montez sur scène pour la
première fois avec votre cousin d'aidé
voilà pour jouer quoi allez vous dire
comment vous savez ça on avait fait une
chanson qui s'appelait à will be home
again d'elvis on avait fait gates doit
aider des caisses qui est devenu
président des états unis je crois qu'il
travaille à l'urssaf à nice
enfin que les fonctionnaires partis très
petit
ouais alors qu'est-ce qui pensèrent les
femmes et ridules du parcours de dick
rivers
comme tout le monde il est déçu non il
aime bien ces il est critique
ouais et forneri de décret il lui
pardonne rien arrêt à huy et ils pensent
quoi hervé forneri quand ils voient
l'amérique aujourd'hui par rapport à
l'image qui se faisait à l'époque les
plus du tout ça non il est très déçu et
hervé forneri l'aiment bien il aime bien
une partie du texas austin notamment qui
est une ville absolument extraordinaire
le montana le wyoming des endroits qui
sont un petit peu comme me l'avait dans
son subconscient quand il était petit
quoi penser que le rêve américain s'est
effondrée le 11 septembre parce que d'un
seul coup avant les américains sont plus
à un refuge sont plus un soutien
c'est pas que ça je trouve que les
américains se sont énormément les
américains bien pensants enfin ceux qui
sont dans les grandes villes se sont
énormément européaniser et que nous on
sait malheureusement énormément
américanisé donc à plus de rêve
ouais je veux dire ça ça paraît bête
mais moi je n'aurais jamais pu penser
qu'un jour il y aurait des mcdo à tous
les coins de rue à paris en province etc
je veux dire quelque part vous en
parliez tout à l'heure mais le hamburger
faisait partie du rêve américain
ouais moi quand j'ai mangé mon premier
hamburger en 1965 à new york avec
marilyn avec marie
enfin bon reste les playmates ça c'est
un truc qui est toujours partie du rêve
vous présenter sur paris première
une émission on voit toutes les filles
de playboy les plaies email
alors faut le dire tout de suite il n'y
a pas de pas de pinet pas de penne
annoncé cool total il pourquoi pas
présenter des porn quand on s'appelle la
[ __ ] dans la rivière on peut y aller il
faut que jeter à l'eau je m'amuse
beaucoup à faire ce truc là mais je ne
crois pas que j'irai jusqu'au port no 1
en 2001 dans l'événement du jeudi vous
aviez de tester le viagra et vous aviez
dit que vous n'avez pas besoin non
seulement je n'ai pas besoin ça je vous
rassure ça va très très bien dit je vais
pas un mec comme a besoin moi c'est
marrant le viagra
on se demande comment ils en vendent
autant finalement ça dépend des
partenaires way a pas quoi que le viagra
et surtout fait quand après les matches
doit y avoir une idée moss ou l'attitude
des partenaires et non moi je vais
raconter
il avait fait un test avec des tas de
gens il y avait il y avait une nagui à
montbard maintenant levé laurent ruquier
qu'avait c'est la junte est endormi mme
al aouiss et vous avez cédera sommé par
sa vie
bien alors différence comme vous êtes
vraiment la star du rock en france en
faire une interview fausse modestie